hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast whole genome sequencing
as a valuable clinical tool for the
management of cancer patients presented
by dr. David Smith professor and
consultant at Mayo Clinic I am Xavier
Gutierrez of lab routes and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want any time you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk located in the promotional
board at the bottom slash center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing educational
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Smith I will turn over the presentation
to him now it's a pleasure to be here to
talk about whole genome sequencing which
can be abbreviated WGS and i'm going to
talk about how I believe this is going
to very quickly become a valuable
clinical tool for the management of
cancer patients if we think about DNA
sequencing the real birth of DNA
sequencing was the development of dye
deoxy sequencing that was developed by
Sanger on in this slide this shows the
four different sequencing reactions that
are done in dye deoxy sequencing to be
able to figure out the determination of
all of the A's all of the g's all of the
season all of the t's are and with this
technology with four separate reactions
one can discern the the sequence of a
small stretch of DNA after the DNA
sequencing reaction is done this is run
on a gel and you can see the bands at
the bottom of the gel and by reading up
the bands and you can see at the very
bottom you can determine the sequence of
that DNA fragment the limitation of this
technology is the ability to separate
the different sized DNA fragments and
with this technology and long sequencing
gels one could sequence of DNA fragments
in length up to six to eight hundred
bases in length however if you want to
sequence something much larger like an
entire genome the next slide shows the
actual strategy that individual DNA
fragments that are overlapping our
sequence separately and then one
assembles them together by looking for
overlaps now there was some discussion a
number of years ago when people were
talking about doing this for something
as complex as an entire genome but it
turns out that this approach which is
known as shotgun sequencing turned out
to be the viable approach for the
sequencing of an entire genome even one
as complex as a human now using this
technology realizing that one needs to
do four lanes for each DNA fragment to
be sequence it turns out that to
sequence the human genome which is
actually six billion base pairs in size
because we have three billion base pairs
of DNA from our mothers and three
billion from our fathers you actually
because you are doing the shotgun
sequencing you actually have to sequence
more than six billion base pairs it's
usually around fifty to sixty billion
base pairs however with this technology
this would have required two hundred and
twenty-two million lanes which would be
at least 20 to 30 million gels and the
cheapest thing I can think of as a
graduate student it would have taken
1,000 graduate students working for 10
years to do this and this just is not a
viable strategy however with the
development of floor
DNA sequencer that was developed by
applied Biosystems which which enables
you to actually do all the sequencing
reactions in a single Lane and then
place this into something and this is
shown here the results of a fluorescent
sequencer you suddenly have the
capability of ramping this up now this
was then put together and instead of
running gels they started running
capillaries and then the evolution of
this all the way to this machine which
was the applied Biosystems 370 which in
1998 was the most advanced sequencer on
the planet you'd have an automated
sequencer that is capable of doing 96
simultaneous sequencing reactions with
this in a three hour run time the output
on this machine was seventy-five
thousand base pairs now a single machine
is clearly not going to be enough to
give you the power to do it you know but
by putting 330 of these machines in a
single room and this is a picture
actually of a company that was actually
doing the sequencing salera genomics and
and this is in Gaithersburg Maryland
this is now a picture that is over 20
years old you see a room with 330 of
these machines and this becomes the
factory for DNA sequencing this was a
significant advance over any of the
sequencing that was done previously and
you can also see that there are very few
people in this very large room this is
very much an automated Factory and by
running 330 machines simultaneously and
continuously running them you can
generate sufficient sequence that in a
relatively short period of time it
turned out to be about three months that
you could generate the necessary sixty
billion base pairs of DNA sequence now
the strengths and weaknesses of the
sequencing by Sanger which is also known
as CER capillary electrophoresis the
strengths were that it was highly
accurate the Sanger sequencing was about
99.99% accurate it turns out that they
didn't just do the shotgun sequencing
but they leveraged other technologies
including including genetic linkage
physical mapping to develop the genome
sequence but the weaknesses were that it
was extremely costly this
cost altogether the the development of
the machines the buying of the machines
about three billion dollars and it was
still three months of sequencing and
multiple months for the assembly of the
resulting sequence now in order to take
this type of technology and bringing the
sequence to the masses it was necessary
to figure ways to dramatically decrease
the cost of genome sequencing it raises
the question of how much for a genome
before it becomes a standard part of
clinical practice it's kind of a trick
question because if you're just saying
you want a sequence everyone on the
planet you probably would think of a
very cheap sequencing cost but if you
have a child which is sick and you're
very much worried about it I'm sure
you're willing to spend considerably
more but in reality you still have to
figure figure out ways to bring the cost
of genome sequencing down not just one
or two orders of magnitude but almost 1
million to 10 million times but in order
to do that there are two main problems
for cap really electro seee sequencing
the first is that each individual
fragment had to be cloned into e.coli
and the second one was that each
individual sequencing reaction which by
itself doesn't seem like a lot of volume
ten microliters but that still uses a
considerable amount of reagents so how
can we solve these two problems well the
first one is by figuring a way to
replace cloning the purpose of cloning
was the amplification of an individual
fragment that was not contaminated with
other fragments now the solution is to
use some sort of PCR strategy but you
still need a strategy where you amplify
individual fragments if you take an
entire genome and all the pieces and
just do PCR you're going to be
amplifying all the pieces together so
you need a strategy where the fragments
are isolated from each other so that you
can make a sufficient number of copies
of each individual fragment to get
enough of the signal for sequencing and
then there were actually two different
strategies that were developed the first
actually this is the first developers
emulsion PCR but I listed bridge
amplification as the first one because
it's the more elegant strategy but
you have bridge amplification and
emulsion PCR has two different
strategies whereby you don't need to
clone the pieces in e.coli whereby you
can actually amplify enough individual
fragments represent an entire genome the
second thing is to figure a way to
reduce that 10 micro litre reaction of
capillary electrophoresis now how can
one do this well it turns out the very
first strategy developed was the use of
Piko titer plates these are plates where
the individual well in the plate holds a
pika leader type volume so we're talking
about not ten microliters or 10 nano
liters but 50 Pico liters which is
significantly less now these pico titer
plates were actually developed by taking
a fiber-optic cable from the
telecommunication industry slicing it
like a salami and then basically putting
a plastic coating on the bottom so you
have a plate where inside the plate
there is one and a half million Wells
each well will hold 50 Pico liters of
volume the second strategy which is not
to use those Pico titer plates at all
but was actually to put clusters of
amplified DNA fragments on a slide
surface the the most important thing was
to use a strategy which is a very
powerful strategy that was used in the
computer industry which is why computers
are so powerful today and that's the
fact that using massively parallel
computing instead of having a single
processor chip you have millions of
processor chips and then the same
strategy for sequencing is instead of
doing an individual sequencing reaction
or like on an ABI 370 96 simultaneous
sequencing reactions is to do something
where you could actually do hundreds of
thousands to millions to ultimately
billions of simultaneous sequencing
reactions the first generation were pico
titer plates and those contain 1.5
million wells now massively parallel
sequencing bus sparks a revolution you
amplify individual fragments to produce
enough template for sequencing you
sequence hundreds of thousands of these
amplified fragment simultaneously you
utilize considerably less sequencing
reagent
her amplified fragment and all of this
together the use of massively parallel
sequencing is known as next-generation
sequencing or abbreviated NGS now this
next slide shows what is done for bridge
amplification for bridge amplification
the entire fragments for a genome are
fragmented and to a very relatively
small size and then there are sequencing
primers that are put on the ends of each
fragments you could call one color the
pink one a and the blue one B these DNA
fragments are then flowed over a cell
surface and this surface actually has
complementary Oliver nucleotides that
are complementary to the a and Bialik of
nucleotides that are placed on the end
of each DNA fragment one end of that DNA
fragment will find its complement and
will actually be able to stick to that
and now you have a DNA fragment that is
tethered at one end but at the other end
there is still the other oligonucleotide
and that can actually find its
complement on the slide surface and when
that happens you've actually have a DNA
fragment that is now bent over where it
has an a-type on one side of B on the
other and now you have a template and a
single DNA fragment which in the
presence of polymerase can make a copy
if you then take that and denature it
you have two fragments and those can
also bend over and by repeating the
cycle about 30 times you can actually do
something where you're amplifying each
individual fragment to on this this
strategy about 30,000 copies but across
the entire surface you have a series of
different amplified fragments that are
now 30,000 copies where there was a
single one and each one is separate from
every other one so you have this
capability of amplifying each individual
fragment without any contamination from
another fragment the other strategy is
known as emulsion PCR it is very similar
you take your DNA and the DNA is again
fragment into small pieces and you put
the two walakum nucleotides at the ends
so this is very similar but instead of
doing this on a slide surface what you
do is you actually do this
a water lipid emulsion and in this
emulsion if you Sonic eight water and
lip it together you can actually produce
these very tiny little water droplets in
the lipid and they are also Pico liter
in volume now in these in this you also
have a very tiny beat first generation
of this was a twenty eight micron beat
on the surface of the beat are these
complimentary alga nucleotides so each
individual beat is very similar to the
surface on the this flow cell of the
previous strategy and in this beat with
a DNA fragment you can you have the
capability of amplifying an individual
fragment to a very large number of
copies with a twenty-eight micron bead
and this type of strategy you could
actually make 1 million copies of each
individual fragment you do this in a
very dilute solution so that most beads
don't amplify any DNA because you don't
want the concentration of DNA to be so
high that beads are amplifying more than
a single DNA fragment but it's very easy
to purify those beads that have
amplified DNA from those that do not so
after this amplification process you
break these emotions you purify the
beads and then you use basically a
weight selection like something like a
sucrose gradient to separate those beats
that have amplified DNA fragments that
those that don't and yet these beads are
so small that one can produce billions
of these beads in a 1.5 mil micro
centrifuge tube now the very first next
generation DNA sequencer was developed
by a company called 454 that comes out
of Connecticut their first machine was
called the GS 20 it was called GS 20
because it was a genome sequencer and
the 20 referred to the fact that the
output from this machine when it first
came out was 20 mega bases now this is a
significant advance because I mentioned
earlier that the ABI 370 which was the
most advanced DNA sequencer in 1998 had
the capability of doing 75,000 base
pairs per sequence per sequence run
whereas this machine when it first
started had an output of 20 mega bases
so this is significant it's it's
basically a 500 fold increase in output
this machine is coupled with which is
shown on the next slide the emulsion PCR
so the individual DNA fragments are
amplified in these separate emulsions
those are purified and then these these
individual beads with amplified DNA are
basically placed and onto this map
ecotype plate that has some 1.5 million
wells each individual fragment is then
placed in these wells and in addition to
these these amplify 28 micron beads are
all the necessary reagents the DNA DNA
ntps the polymerase etc for the
sequencing reaction it's placed into the
pico titer plate and it's placed into
the Machine and it's set up in such a
way that you can then flow one at a time
individual alkyl nucleotides so
individual nucleotides excuse me so
first you place an A and you see which
one of these beads is incorporating an A
is the first base the enzymes that are
set up for this are set up so that when
a base is incorporated there will be a
flash of light this is known as pyro
sequencing so you thought you flood the
entire Pico titer played with an A and
you ask which of the wells has given a
flash of light then gonna see a G and a
T and that's the interpretation of the
first base if one then utilizes this on
the right one sees the output from one
of these single beads but you have to
realize that across the entire Pico
titer plate there are at least a half
million of these beads with an
individual DNA fragment and on this you
can actually see the strengths but also
the weakness of this technology because
the nucleotides themselves are unblocked
which means that if you have a string of
A's for example that entire string of
A's is going to be incorporating T's so
if there's only a single base that's
incorporated you see a peak at a certain
height as you go across that top slide
you see suddenly a peak where there is
multiple nucleotides being added and one
can tell the difference between a single
base being added to basis and three
bases but if one has a long homo polymer
stretch and a long enough stretch it's
very difficult to tell a difference for
example between 10 and
11 A's but one of the nice things about
this technology is that it gives a
strong signal because there is 1 million
amplified DNA fragments on each bead and
one can get a long sequence read when
this day this is showing 191 base pair
read but with this technology it was
possible to get reeds that were very
similar in length to the length of of
reeds that you were getting with Sanger
sequencing the strengths and weaknesses
of this where there were long reads when
they started there was 400 base pairs
there were rapid improvements to this
technology but the weakness was the
emulsion PCR is a very messy technique
that requires this lipid water interface
the fact is that you have homopolymers
because the nucleotides are not blocked
and the biggest problem was there was
limited Headroom for further increases
in sequencing outlet now when this
machine started was called the GS 20
very quickly it was capable of 40 mega
bases of sequence and meant a hundred
mega bases and actually through the life
of this instrument it increased its
output but what happened was very
quickly they they reached a point where
you couldn't get anymore sequences on
this instrument so by the time this
thing had been reached its penultimate
instrument we had something that was
known as the GS flex titanium the Wells
themselves were coated with titanium but
it was capable now of 500 mega bases of
sequence output per run and of course of
$6,000 but it was not possible to get
further output however where is the very
first genome cause almost 3 billion
dollars to sequence in 2007 as a
promotional thing they sequenced the
genome of Jim Watson of Watson Crick
Fame and on this platform utilizing a
500 mega base output per run the cost
for sequencing Watson's genome was just
1 million dollars so we've already seen
a dramatic improvement of basically 3
billion dollars for a genome down to 1
million dollars but clearly our target
is going to be a much less expensive
genome we could argue about what is the
cost of a genome at which point it
becomes very useful for routine clinical
practice but it is clear that
this improvement which is basically a
3,000 fold improvement from Sanger
sequencing we're still gonna have to
figure out a strategy to improve this
multiple orders of magnitude better well
it turns out Illumina and this is the
very first Illumina machine that was
produced this was produced in 2007 this
was known as the GA for the genome
analyzer this platform utilized the
different way of amplified DNA and this
was amplifying DNA using bridge
amplification so using bridge
amplification one can amplify individual
DNA fragments on the left of the slide
is the actual flow cell that is used in
the very first generation Illumina
machine it's actually still used in the
current generation Illumina machines
which is basically a flow cell that is
eight separate lanes this enables you to
put separate reactions in each lane if
you wanted to you could put the same
reaction in multiple lanes if you wanted
the output to be greater and then this
flow cell can be placed in a machine now
the nice thing about the Illumina
platform in addition to using a much
better way of amplifying DNA in bridge
amplification is the fact that they are
using individual labelled nucleotides
that are different fluorescent colors so
that G's are one color of the C's the
t's and these are different colors the
color is a floor that is attached to
each individual nucleotide but it is
nicely added at a position where when a
nucleotide is added the floor is
blocking the addition of the next base
so this blocking enables you to put one
base at a time so you actually will and
you will flow all four together
simultaneously you don't have to do one
at a time across the flow cell and then
after that is done you wash everything
that is not incorporated away and a
camera will take a picture the next step
is to remove the fluorescent blocking
group by doing that chemically removing
that the thing is it now able to accept
the next base and one does that takes a
picture of that and you can see on the
right hand side the top one is the first
base incorporated the second one is the
second base that you continue that
process you wash everything away you
take off the block fluorescence and you
do the third base
the force base etc and you can see for
example the sequence of the little
certain the little circle that is on the
left is G C G G a and that is the
sequence of that base but simultaneously
you're doing the sequence of all the
other amplified ones at the same time
hence the massively parallel sequencing
now the advances on this platform the
original machine was a significant
advance because it was capable of a Giga
base of sequence and remember that the
454 even its penultimate machine was
only capable of 500 mega bases but they
were to do this we had 48 million
clusters but the size of the sequence
that was generated was only 31 base
pairs and these were relatively short
however over the next three years they
increased the number of clusters that
could be read and the read length of
individual fragments that was sequence
was up to a hundred base pairs and this
resulted in a dramatic increase in the
number of Giga bases that could be
sequenced and at a higher accuracy
however four years after the very first
machine came out an improvement that
this came out and this is shown here and
this is the high C 2000 this machine had
a number of improvements from the
previous machine instead of doing a
single flow cell that realization was
that while you're doing the chemistry on
one flow cell it would be a good time to
actually take pictures of the other flow
cell so this machine actually ran two
flow cells at a time in addition the
clusters that were produced on the flow
cell turned out to be not just on the
top of the slide but on the bottom of
the slide so the high C 2000 had the
ability to actually read both the top
slide on the bottom of the slide so this
increased the output dramatically these
machines had even greater output but as
shown on the slide here at the bottom
right is after a while you start to
produce so many clusters on the slide
surface then it becomes very difficult
to tell one cluster from another how
does one increase this so that one can
get even greater output and the answer
to that question was to instead of just
having a flat slide surface on the flow
cell is to have a pattern flow cell
technology that is shown on the bottom
left
where each individual fragment is not
amplified on a flat surface but in an
individual well and then when one does
sequencing with this and if you see the
bottom in the middle you can see that
it's very easy to discern one sequence
site from another and this results in
the ability to get even higher densities
unfortunately in the same way that the
very first generation machine had a very
short life the high Sikhs themselves had
a short life with the replacement of
these pattern flow cells and each of
these machines was costing seven hundred
thousand dollars but two to three years
later was obsolete because of these
advances in technology the next slide
shows the current version of the
Illumina machine which is known as the
Nova see the nova seek is using the
pattern flow cells again there's
actually two versions of this machine
that is shown on the next slide though
nova seek 5000 which runs a single slide
and the nova seek 6000 which ones too
and one of the nice things about this
system was the output was even greater
remember the first generation Illumina
machine was capable of a Giga base of
sequencing but on the Nova see with the
smallest flow cell you capable of
producing 500 gigabases or half a
terabyte recently the three tera base
flow cell has come out this means that
one can do six tera bases are 6,000 bate
Giga bases of sequence to per sequence
run so the output on this machine is
absolutely incredible
now with this type of technology the
capability of doing 6 tera bases of
sequence every time you run this machine
you have the capability of doing a lot
of different types of sequencing one
type of sequencing which I'm really is
the major subject of what I'm talking
about today is whole genome sequencing
or WGS to do WGS you need to do about a
hundred Giga bases of sequencing per
normal genome however there are many
reasons why you may not want to do that
much sequencing and one possible
solution is just to sequence defined
portions of the genome that you want to
look at in a clinical setting that might
be a
group of genes that are involved in the
disease that you're actually studying if
you want to sequence at less than a
whole genome but don't want to sequence
just this very small portion one can do
whole exome sequencing which is known as
W he s and this is the sequencing of the
200,000 exons that comprises the coding
portion of the genome another thing that
can be done with this technology is
transcriptome sequencing this is
actually the sequencing of what is
actively being transcribed in cells and
it's basically taking the RNA from cells
and converting it into DNA and one uses
a cDNA approach towards this and then
one can figure out what is being
actively transcribed in a cell one can
also not just sequence the DNA but can
sequence the DNA that has been
epigenetically modified by methylation
and then one can determine portions of
the genome that are more susceptible to
environmental influences so you have
with the capability of a nova seek
machine the ability to do a variety of
different types of sequencing and then
one has to evaluate these to say which
one of these is best for which specific
use well whole genome sequencing as I
said requires one to sequence at least a
hundred Giga bases if one is sequencing
at cancer genome and if the cancer
genome has heterogeneity and this is
seen in a number of cancers most notably
in breast cancer you might need to
sequence more than a 100 Giga bases if
you're looking at a population of cells
that is only 10 percent of the total and
you want to see them at sequence them
fully you're gonna probably need to
sequence up to a terabyte of sequence
but once you've generated the sequence
on these machines you have millions of
fragments and they're being in a
sequence but that still needs to be
assembled together one must look for
overlaps between these fragments the
other part which is a very critical
component is to analyze the assemble
genome and one has to ask the question
what are you looking for what types of
alterations are you looking for
alterations of individual nucleotides
are you looking for alterations that
that comprise basically changes in the
DNA like amplification are you looking
for translocations all of these things
add complexity to the overall
problem now for defined portions of the
genome again one could ask the question
why sequence and assemble all six Giga
bases of you genome what about examining
specific regions or genes for specific
tests and again it could be a small
panel of genes or it could be the entire
exome which is again 200,000 exons
but it's only 38 mega bases well the
first question is how does one enriched
for whatever defined portion of the
genome you want and on the next slide
one sees the strategy that's actually
done by Agilent which is they're sure
select but there are very similar
strategies from other companies and what
one does is one producers and this is
shown on the top right beats and these
baits are actually sequences that you
want to capture their biotin elated and
then the DNA from the entire genome is
fragmented into small pieces there are a
PCR primers which are also sequencing
primers that are put on the end of each
of these fragments one uses the baits to
fish for the sequences that you want
when you actually then put them together
you have pieces with the biotin elated
baits and this is the perfect thing to
attract with a magnetic bead that's
coated with streptavidin the
streptavidin will bind the biotin lated
have pieces and then you can pull those
pieces out with a magnet and then
frankly the allah' can do CLE tides at
the end of the fragments can be used to
PCR what you have captured and the nice
thing about this is whatever you want to
do if you want to capture the exons of
ten genes you can do this if you want to
capture the exons of the entire EXO ball
200,000 that can also be done in this
very small tube now how are the baits
made they're actually made using
hewlett-packard based printing because
Agilent is actually a company that comes
from Hewlett Packard and one of the nice
things about color printing is color
printing uses four different colors well
the same thing that comes in groups of
four are the individual nucleotides so
instead of making a color picture as you
would with a printer you actually use
that same technology but you put the
four bases in that substitute them for
the colors and then you can synthesize
on a slide surface millions of different
long islet of nucleotides like you would
sort of print a color picture and then
once that's done you can actually remove
all the solid nucleotides from the slide
surface because usually they're
connected by a self hydro bond and then
you have them in a tube and you suddenly
have the baits for the sequences that
you would like to capture now whole
exome sequencing is basically baits with
all 200,000 exons which is again 38.5
mega bases the nice thing about this is
on a nova seek machine of a small
fraction of alene is sufficient to
sequence the entire exome of an
individual or of a cancer or whatever
you want to look at and still you're
gonna read every single nucleotide that
you've captured at greater than two
hundred fold depth so the advantage of
this is that you can do greater depth as
you're sequencing it and it requires so
much less sequencing to capture an
entire exome if one uses a nova seek
machine which is capable of producing
six tera bases of sequence that is
sufficient sequencing to sequence 60
individuals for whole genome sequencing
but it's actually useful you can do
hundreds of multiple hundreds of exomes
each time you run the machine so whole
exome sequencing is a much cheaper way
to characterize a portion of the genome
transcriptome sequencing is useful
because whole genome sequencing or
define region sequencing or exome
sequencing only tells you what's in the
DNA and does not reveal what is actively
being transcribed in a Cell
so transcriptome sequencing analyzed
which transcribed however when one
isolates RNA 95% of that RNA has
ribosomal
which you're not interested in so one
needs to figure a way to get rid of the
ribosome on RNA and that can be removed
either by capturing the tran the
transcribed sequences which when they're
coding sequences are Polident elated or
by using baits for the ribosomal RNA to
remove them and then once that's removed
you can sequence the rest now what can
you detect with RNA sequence and RNA
sequencing known as RNA see you can see
transcript abundance but with a digital
output and this is so much better than
microarrays because you get a digital
output and it's possible to see
transcripts that are even relatively
rare with microarrays it's very
difficult to see the bottom 50% of
Xpress transepts with RNA see one can
see almost everything that is actively
transcribed one can see transcript
isoforms one can see fused transcripts
which could be there both isoforms and
fused transcripts could be very
important in a cancer context and since
you're actually sequencing each
nucleotide you're actually able to see
mutations in the most abundantly
expressed transcripts and it totally
depends on how much sequencing you do as
to which transcripts you can see with a
low-pass sequencing you can only see the
most you can see the sequence of the
most abundantly expressed transcripts
with high sequencing one can see the
sequence of most of the transcripts so
this is a powerful technology
methylation sequencing and with there's
multiple different types of epigenetic
modifications of the DNA but the one we
focus on the most is 5-methylcytosine
and this is the methylation of cytosine
which as I said is indicative of
environmental exposure well at an
example just out of my own life
what most older Americans become lactose
intolerant because as they get older
then the lactase gene becomes methylated
and this is why I can't eat ice cream or
milk or any of those things because my
lactase gene has become methylated again
this is indicative of Aging or
environmental exposure but one can look
at methylation of a genome with this
type of technology now each of these has
strengths and weaknesses whole genome
sequencing has a number of strengths but
also some weaknesses again with the
Novus seek and pattern flow cells the
cost to generate a hundred Giga bases of
sequence is only $350 but this is just
the cost for sequencing how much does it
cost to assemble the genome and
interpret it what about alterations
outside of the coding sequence because
they're only two percent of the genome
actually codes for protein but in a
cancer cell there will be alterations
throughout the genome what is the
clinical significance of those
alterations even within alterations with
the coding sequence of the genome which
of those alterations are actionable and
this is a very small fraction the other
issue is that even after you've
generated the sequence even
after you assemble the sequence together
and analyze it how much does it cost to
store that data and thus generally this
is not ready for primetime clinical
practice in most settings now the
strengths and weaknesses of exome
sequencing its strengths as it's cheaper
than whole genome sequencing one
generates much greater sequence depth
for most bases it's considerably easier
by automatically because you have much
less to analyze and of course this much
less data to store however because
you're using a capture technique which
is not capturing every single nucleotide
at the same level you do not get 100% of
the target bases sometimes there are
bases that are not gotten at sufficient
depth to be able to discern with their
sequences in addition one generates no
information outside of the exome or
whatever was targeted and if you're
trying to figure out anything other than
the changes in the nucleotides for
example copy number variation it's
difficult to take exome sequencing and
determine what's going on in terms of
changes in copy number across a genome
the strengths and weaknesses of RNA
sequencing or RNA seek is that it
complements all the other technology
it's much easier by automatically
especially for message abundance and of
course is even less than at a store
however by itself it does not provide
information about genomic changes
outside of the exo strengths and
weaknesses of methylation sequencing is
even though the strength is it's a
better indicator of mind exposure and
it's very complementary to other
techniques especially RNA seek but in
order to generate full methylation
sequencing this requires you to take the
entire genome bisulfite modify it and
one sequence is the unmodified genome
and then the modified genome and one
looks for the changes and those changes
are where there is a 5-methylcytosine
but the classical model of how
methylation specifically methylation of
CPG Islands controls gene expression is
being challenged and actually many
people are starting to believe that it
could be plain wrong
so we don't really know which
methylations across the genome are
important for changing gene expression
hence a lot of methylation sequencing is
going to generate data that we can't
make any sense out of now what is the
cost of next
generation sequencing and this is for
all types of Jetix generation sequencing
the first cost is the generation of the
library and this totally depends on the
type of library you're making now one of
the things is that one could figure a
way to reduce this cost by making the
reaction volumes even smaller instead of
these 10 microliters sequencing
reactions could win reduce the reaction
violence to much less well this
companies like Gen cell or advanced
liquid logic that have the capability of
producing libraries but not in 10 micro
liter but 10 nano liter volumes which
means that one uses less reagents
there's the actual cost of the
sequencing itself and this totally
depends on what you're sequencing and
how deep you want to go but obviously if
sequence output increases the overall
cost of sequencing decreases the biggest
bottleneck of this entire strategy is
analysis and it's a bottleneck of the
entire technology and it totally depends
again on what you're sequencing if
there's less analysis if one is doing
RNA see less analysis if one is doing a
small gene panel there's much more
analysis if one is doing an entire
genome for whole genome sequencing or
for the methylome if one's doing the
entire methylome and of course another
important part of a cost is the storage
of the data and again which technology
use determines how much that's going to
cost if you're just doing RNA seek
there's much less data if you're doing
whole genome sequencing there's much
more data now what are the clinical uses
of whole genome sequencing today the
very first use of it is in the NICU
units of the neonatal intensive care
units because a child is born is failing
to thrive parents are obviously upset
and hysterical and they want to know
what is wrong with their child and in a
very quick setting well it turns out
this was pioneered by Stephen Kingsmore
and his colleagues and now they have
developed strategies where they've taken
whole genome sequencing and are capable
of doing this I say 26 hours here but
I've recently read that this is down to
23 hours and as a result of this he's
actually in the Guinness Book of World
Records for the fastest turnaround time
for genome sequencing and this is
important because you can basically take
some DNA from a new
oran generate the whole genome
sequencing analyze it and half the data
and the analysis ready 24 hours later
when the doctors are rotating to each of
the patients to see what is wrong with
that patient and this is really
transforming what's happening in NICU
units if you don't want to do whole
genome sequence and a cheaper strategy
might be whole exome sequencing but
again this is you specifically in the
neonatal intensive care units setting
and the whole genome sequencing is not
yet being routinely used at all for
cancer care
now clinical uses of whole exome
sequencing watch you in st. Louis has
been using whole exome sequencing to
pull down all the exons and sequence
them and even though they may not be
interested in all you know 20,000 genes
they can focus on the genes of interest
for example if you have a patient with a
cardiovascular problem you could focus
just on the cardiovascular genes but the
nice thing about this strategy and
technology is that one can develop
databases of alterations in disease and
you could query regions that might turn
out to be significant that you don't
know about when you start and it's not
much more expensive than just focusing
on small gene panels so this is why this
is a powerful technology when you don't
want to do a whole genome sequencing but
you want to still be comprehensive and
looking at the coding portion of the
genome the next-generation cancer panels
are really the strategy that is used
most in a cancer setting for example
foundation medicine has a 315 gene panel
unfortunately they don't really make
money so they're actually doing this but
they're not generating enough money per
test to pay for it but what they are
doing is they're developing databases of
alterations and cancers and this can be
very powerful this is sort of the myriad
model that myriad used for Braca 1 and
bracket 2 memorial SmithKline and
Hopkins are developing 400 plus gene
panels for cancer and it's the same game
plan as foundation medicine they're not
really making money on each test but
their bill at developing databases Mayo
Clinic which is much more concerned
about making money on tests and being
fiscally fund of responsible as a 50
gene cancer panel
they're now working to develop a 400
gene panel many places in Europe are
also developing larger gene cancer
panels but of course for all of these
strong bioinformatics to support this is
extremely key
now what about NGS for clinical cancer
care
currently small G panels of the
sequencing strategy of choice in cancer
care less DNA to sequence much simpler
bioinformatics and it helps to target
important genes and helps to identify
actionable alterations but one still has
to realize even with a 300 gene panel
the alterations that one detect the vast
majority of alterations are not
clinically actionable there is no drug
currently available even if a gene is
mutated now what are the problems with
small gene panels this only provides
information about the genes that you
target no information about copy number
alterations no information about gene
fusions and the total cost includes the
capture which is not cheap it actually
turns out that to capture a small number
of genes or to capture an exome is about
similar in costs and it still is a
significant cost and there's no
information about alien DNA DNA that is
present there such as viruses unless
that's actually put and targeted in the
baits that you utilize now whole genome
sequencing for cancer care a key
strength is it provides complete
information about a cancer it identifies
most of the single nucleotide
polymorphism or snips it identifies the
copy number variants the translocations
etc whatever DNA is present in what
you're studying will be sequenced so it
identified foreign DNA such as viruses
and it's a much simpler library prep
with no need for enrichment so actually
the cheapest prep for any of the NGS is
for whole genome sequencing one simply
takes all the DNA fragments puts on the
suitable sequencing primers and
basically takes that in sequence it so
it's actually cheaper to produce the
library than some of the other
techniques where it becomes more
expensive is one needs to sequence more
DNA to cover the entire genome so what
will it take for whole genome sequencing
to become the clinical test for cancer
well the first thing is the total cost
for whole genome sequencing must be less
for many years people were talking about
the thousand dollar genome but I'm
actually a big fan of a hundred dollar
genome and when I mean a hundred dollar
genome I mean total cost all in so that
everything library preparation
sequencing analysis altogether must be a
hundred dollars because at that point
small gene panels are whole exome
sequencing just the capture itself cost
a couple you know one to two hundred
dollars for the panels or whole exome
sequencing why do them when you can do
whole genome and have comprehensive
genome information for a fraction of the
cost
quicker turnaround time but it turns out
that's already been solved by Stephen
Kingsmore and his work in the NICU units
but that raises the question when will
the cost of whole genome sequencing be
$100 or less one of the things I did not
mention is that in the sequencing world
there is a monopoly that is now
controlled by the company Illumina some
90 to 95 percent of the sequencing
that's done on this planet is done on
the Illumina platform and without
significant contribution kind you know
without significant competition there is
no motivation for a company like
Illumina to generate a genome for a
fraction of that cost so the question is
is there some competition for aluminum
well it turns out that there is BGI
stands for the Beijing genome Institute
used to be in Beijing but is now in
Shenzhen which is sort of the free zone
in China and basically BGI
has very ambitious plans they have plans
to do a million newborns Chinese people
who known as their million newborn
cohorts they are doing a million plants
and animal genomes they want to do
millions multiple millions of
microorganisms and the the cng B which
is the China National gene Bank is an
incredible facility that I've had the
honour of being at and they are they're
storing 20 million samples they're doing
1,000 plus sequencing machines they have
8 petabytes of data that's generated
each day and this is a very big
sequencing place and they have a
sequencing platform that actually could
be competition which is shown here this
was a strategy developed by write a
dramatic for the company complete
genomics
they still needin a third strategy for
amplifying individual DNA fragments and
the strategy that they use is called
nano balls you take small little DNA
fragments that are then circularized and
then the pleasance of a5 polymerase you
can take those little circles and
amplify them with a rolling circle
amplification so that each individual
fragment be amplified to 300 copies
these amplified DNA s then curl up into
these tiny little balls that are known
as an aníbal and you can see in a small
little tube you can have a hundred
billion little nano balls each
individual nano ball can be placed on a
spot and on this type of sequence you
have four billion slots spots per slide
with in this case 600 nanometer
separation between the spots and then
these are taken and DNA sequencing can
be done on this initially BG I would do
all their sequencing in-house but very
recently they develop machine known as
the BG I seek 500 which is a DNA an
animal based efficient bench top
sequencer and it is been approved by the
China FDA it uses stepwise sequencing by
polymerase the output on this machine
first generation was about 300 Giga
bases and there were over 400 BG I see
five hundredths that have been deployed
now there is a manufacturing component
of this and they're producing the MGIC
500 which is just the manufactured BG IC
and these machines are starting to be
sent to various places they're not yet
currently available in the United States
there may be some issues of
patentability in terms of how the
sequencing is done but this machine has
the capability of producing types of
sequence output that begins to be
comparable to what's done on aluminum
now it turns out BGI is now willing to
do whole genome sequencing for a total
cost of $600 but by the end of this year
that is going to be reduced to $200 and
they are targeting the hundred dollar
genome total and cost by the end of 2019
and this is significant competition is
thus good because as BGI ram stores
providing $100 all in humans you know
aluminum will have no choice but to try
to compete and thus we've seen a
reduction in a whole genome sequencing
cost from three billion dollars to $600
down to $100 in about 19 years and once
we have $100 genome one can ask the
question well when was that going to be
will all we need is a tenfold
improvement to the cost of a genome is
just ten dollars and maybe that'll be
the next target so whole genome
sequencing for cancer easy library prep
ultimately less expensive than any other
next-generation sequencing approach it
provides complete genome information
including snips CNVs translocations and
foreign DNA and whole genome sequencing
diet and cancer well one could take the
data that's once generating with these
100 dollar genomes and the very first
thing one can do is molecular
characterize each cancer as we're
starting to see out of projects like the
TCGA project by sequencing sufficient
numbers of cancers one can use molecular
classifications that make that are
already turning out to be more powerful
than pathology characterization to get
molecular subgroups of each cancer this
is first seen in breast cancer and also
in lung cancer and one can see that
different types of molecular
characterizations of different cancers
will have different outcomes and also
different treatment strategies now the
different subtypes again as at will have
different treatment strategies and this
can still be used to identify actionable
mutations the only difference is that is
such a small proportion of the total
number of alterations that one sees in a
genome are going to be actionable even a
small percentage of a 400 gene panel are
actionable and Eve much smaller
percentage out of an entire genome now
what is the problems with whole genome
sequencing for cancer again most
alterations detector will be outside the
coding portion of the genome what do
they even mean however there was a very
interesting recent paper that came out
of the rule Senayan lab where they're
showing a long non-coding RNA which is
involved in prostate cancer that itself
might be a target so as more and more
sequencing is done as more and more work
is done on the alterations that one sees
in cancer we're going to start to find
alterations outside of the coding
portion of the genome that themselves
could be potentially actionable but even
a small proportion of the alterations in
the coding portion of jump are
concurrently actionable which means that
we need many more drugs for mutating
genes to really be useful we're also
gonna have to have much more information
about how multiple drugs that are
targeting different alterations work
together how toxic they are etc and
there's a huge amount of data which is
way too expensive to store the full
sequence so we're going to need some
solutions or maybe just storing the
important alterations are figuring out
different ways where we can bring down
the cost of data storage so that wooden
doesn't have a hundred dollar genome
that cost ten thousand dollars to store
in terms of data however whole genome
sequencing provides information on
cancer specific mutations and cancer
specific mutations are valuable markers
for monitoring cancers and this can be
used in two different ways one is as a
potential diagnostic tool for cancer
screening and this is being employed by
the company Grail that is trying to
develop tests where they can screen
populations of individuals for known
alterations found in cancer but more
importantly until that has been
developed one can still use this to
detect the presence of cancer cells and
potentially the amount of cancer present
in an individual undergoing clinical
treatment and this brings up the entire
concept of the liquid biopsy since
metastatic solid tumors and actually
blood confers as well I have those cells
in the blood the circulating tumor DNA
that is present it can be detected in
the blood the half-life of this DNA is
very short which means that if you
figure a way to eradicate or decrease
the number of cancer cells where the
cancer is that the circulating DNA that
came from that cancer with a short
half-life is going to decrease very
rapidly since the concentration of
circulating free tumor day may be very
low and is only a fraction as compared
to normal DNA how can one detect such
rare DNA so well it turns out that can
be done with a number of techniques but
one powerful one is known as digital
droplet PCR or dd PCR this can be used
to identify rare sequence variants
such as rare molecules that have
mutations and the ways these this is
done is very similar to the droplets
that we use for emulsion PCR you produce
these individual droplets and you put
very dilute DNA in the droplets and
there are two platforms that were
available one was this bio-rad QX 200
droplet digital PCR system which
produced some 50,000 droplets the
alternative was a rain dance system
which produce up to 10 million droplets
well it turns out by rad bought rain
dance so that they can control this
entire market and you basically have
technologies where you can produce large
numbers of individual droplets you
dilute the DNA that's isolated from the
blood into the droplets you amplify them
and as shown here on the next slide you
take their DNA you amplify them and you
are looking for specific alterations
that are present in that DNA with these
types of machines you can look for as
many as five or six independent
alterations you do the PCR then you you
read this thing and you say how many of
these droplets contain this altered
nucleotide so this is a nucleotide by
nucleotide examination and one can say
if you see one drop of that as an
altered DNA in the presence of several
thousand that are normal that is the
concentration of the mutant molecule to
the total and then one could use this to
monitor an individual's going through
treatment so to use DDT PCR to monitor
cancers you identify your tumor specific
markers it could be a mutation in the
tumor or a novel Junction the metastatic
tumors will be circulating to add a
present in the blood but it'll be a low
concentration relative to normal but one
can isolate this optimize for
circulating DNA and then one could look
for whether there are mutant molecules
and this also produces a digital output
because you can tell the ratio of the
mutant droplets to the normal droplets
and that tells you the concentration and
then one can monitor by going through
therapy so for example you identify your
can't specific alterations for home of
whole genome sequencing data you
construct PCR primers for these
alterations that are patient's specific
and then ones DD PCR in the blood
samples to monitor the patient's post
surgery as well as post on the treatment
and if for example the surgery has been
effective one has eradicated all the
cancer very quickly
there'll be no circulating DNA from the
tumor and one could say that that
patient has no more circulating free DNA
perhaps the surgery has been effective
if you're using this to monitor other
things like chemotherapy or radiotherapy
one can still do this to see in
real-time how patients are responding to
these therapies and one gets a very
quick feedback and one can tell if the
therapy is working or not if the therapy
is not working why treat patients with
toxic compounds so whole genome
sequencing has the potential to
completely change how we treat cancer
patients when the total cost of whole
genome sequence is 100 dollars it will
become the technique of choice for
characterizing cancers it's cheaper and
easier than gene panels are even whole
exome sequencing it's a comprehensive
way examining genome wide alterations
one can focus on those alterations that
are actionable and use the simultaneous
use the data generated symbolically
reclassify each cancer one can thus use
the liquid biopsy to follow cancer
treatments in real time so this is the
end of my presentation basically these
technologies are going to completely
transform how we treat cancer patients
is my firm belief that when the cost of
a genome is 100 dollars we're going to
rapidly see the adoption of this as a
methodology for cancer patients actually
we're going to start to see this as the
methodology that's used in the normal
population as well and in the next
couple of years we're going to see a
transformation and how we treat cancer
patients we're gonna start to treat with
a very personalized approach individual
cancer patients to understand what's
altered in their individual cancer to
molecularly classify them then to find
the right drugs for treating that cancer
and using the liquid biopsy to monitor
so this revolution is exciting it's
exciting to be a part of it and I advise
anyone in population is thinking of
getting cancer to just wait a few years
because our ability to treat cancer is
going to be so much better five years
from now than it is today and I thank
you for your attention
Thank You dr. Smith for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you do
have a question you'd like to ask we
used to so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click on the send button why answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for all right let's get started our
first question is how does next
generation sequencing compared to Sanger
sequencing with respect to sequence
accuracy this is an important question
when next generation sequencing first
started it was not as accurate as Sanger
sequencing so people thought of Sanger
sequencing is the gold standard and
next-generation sequencing as being less
accurate however the advances in
next-generation sequencing have gotten
to the point now where because of the
sequence output that is possible and by
sequencing so each individual nucleotide
a sufficient number of times one gets
this a similar type of accuracy as
Sanger sequencing and as a result my
prediction is that Sanger sequencing is
going to over the next couple of years
be replaced almost completely by
next-generation sequencing all right
thank you
second question will next-generation
sequencing replace Sanger sequencing and
how soon well the Sanger sequencing for
molecular tests as over the past 10
years really become extremely popular
but as people start to use
next-generation sequencing and start to
do gene panels we're starting to see at
the Mayo Clinic it's starting to replace
Sanger sequencing so my and my guess is
over the next couple of years we're
going to see more and more
next-generation sequencing and less and
less Sanger sequencing unless you're
just interpreting and looking at a
single gene for example if you're doing
a cystic fibrosis test there really is
no reason to do next-generation
sequencing but over the next couple of
years the NGS is going to replace Sanger
sequencing
why our small gene panels the current
next-generation sequencing technique of
choice right now for cancer patient
there are a number reasons for this the
major reason is cost because the total
cost of whole genome sequencing is still
too great when one factors in everything
including that analysis and storage the
second thing is that even a small
fraction of the small gene panel have
alterations which are actionable and as
a result it's it becomes more expensive
to do whole genomes and when you're only
looking at a very small fraction of what
is altered and even a company like
foundation medicine that's doing they're
315 gene panel aren't getting their
money back so I think why we're seeing
the small gene panels are used now
because it's just easier to handle less
data less storage
let's bioinformatics but as a whole
genome sequencing becomes cheap enough
and we develop some strategies to solve
some of the problems we're gonna see
that we're gonna see a transition in the
same way that today we're seeing Sanger
sequencing going in next-generation
sequencing we're gonna see small gene
panels go towards whole genome
sequencing okay and we have time for one
more question what will it take for
whole genome sequencing to become the
clinical test for cancer as I discussed
in my talk I think when when the
capability is that you can do an entire
genome for $100 I think we're going to
have very little reasons to do small
gene panels or exomes there still are
significant problems however including
data storage including better ways to
very quickly go to the alterations that
you want to but again when a genome
costs $100 I think we're going to see a
transition and it's my prediction and if
we come back in five years time there's
going to be an awful lot of whole genome
sequencing that's going to be used in
the cancer patient setting all right I
would like to once again thank dr. Smith
for his presentation I'd also like to
thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
I want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through September of 2018 you'll
receive an email from libraries letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye